[Music]
eight news now has learned that two
teens wanted in connection with a
homicide have been taken into custody
it's a story the i-team first broke
yesterday vanessa murphy has been
digging in for more information she
joins us live
at metro police headquarters with the
details vanessa
we've learned one of those teens is
accused of killing her father
she is 16 years old the other suspect is
her 18 year old boyfriend
metro police tell us they were found in
salt lake city this morning and taken
into custody
they were missing since friday now the
boyfriend
is identified as aaron guerrero his
attorney sent the i-team this photo
the i-team also obtained documents
stating utah transit authority police
arrested him on a fugitive warrant at a
train station
now the 16 year old again we've learned
she is the victim's daughter and metro
police say she stole
his car on friday police say they found
the body of 45 year old
daniel halseth in a west valley home and
a fire was set to cover
up the homicide the clark county
coroner's office tells us the cause of
death
is sharp force injuries
it's definitely disturbing when you have
such young
a young man and a young woman that are
being accused of such a horrific crime
and when you look at the crime scene in
its
itself it is definitely something that's
disturbing
halseth is the ex-husband of former
nevada state senator elizabeth hauseth
court documents show they have three
children and one of them
is the 16-year-old girl now daniel
halsett's family sent the i-team
a statement which reads quote our family
is heartbroken this has happened to
daniel we love daniel beyond words
he loved his children and was an amazing
father
we ask for privacy and respect for the
family
at this time and quote